la crisis carcelaria en ecuador no es
una noticia nueva porque se siguen
presentando estos hechos tan violentos y
cuál es la respuesta al hacinamiento y a
la medida de aseguramiento
nacional es una buena tarde para todos
los televidentes el tema aquí es
básicamente que el estado perdió el
control del primer organizado desde
mucho tiempo atrás y especialmente en el
control de los centros carcelarios donde
existen dos factores el 1 es la
altísimos niveles de corrupción y el
segundo la proliferación de mega bandas
que están articulando desde los centros
carcelarios una dinámica de violencia
permanente hacia los centros urbanos eso
es lo que se ve reflejado al momento en
el escenario nacional a esto se le tiene
que sumar dos factores importantes en
uno que es que estas organizaciones del
crimen organizado locales están
comenzando a mutar hacia lo que se
denominan carteles de primera generación
o micro carteles y también a otro factor
el estado no ha podido hasta la presente
fecha manejar un control eficiente sobre
los diferentes centros personales en qué
medidas están las cárceles preparadas
para los motines por qué es tan difícil
para la fuerza pública retomar y control
es sumamente difícil porque el estado no
tiene el control de los centros
carcelarios por un lado y por otro lado
en que el ingreso de armamento a los
centros carcelarios es una actividad
permanente en las diferentes cárceles
del país esto no se ha podido controlar
lamentablemente la corrupción es la que
prima al interior de los centros
carcelarios y está dificultando la tarea
del estado para poder atender
eficientemente la acción y la actividad
que tiene que cumplir la apuesta pública
al interior de los centros capilares no
se ha podido controlar hasta el momento
estos centros carter's y cómo va la
política para intentar eliminar el
hacinamiento
bueno el tema del hacinamiento es uno de
los factores importantes y más que todo
se está pidiendo a la justicia
ecuatoriana que se haga cargo
directamente de la responsabilidad
porque cerca de 16.000 privados de
libertad no tienen al momento sentencia
ejecutoriada entonces se convirtió esto
en un negocio perverso por parte de la
justicia ecuatoriana que trata bajo todo
el concepto de sacar un rédito a esta
estacionamiento y a esta cantidad de
detenidos que tiene allá esperando que
tengan el dinero necesario para poder
comprar su libertad que es una cosa
completamente desastrosa en el tema de
seguridad y en el tema de justicia